hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played two days ago
in the fourth annual play live challenge
where Magnus Carlsen world chess
champion takes on 12 opponents
simultaneously so it's a simultaneous
exhibition as the word suggests and it's
very interesting how I came upon this
game now I just you know woke up as I
usually do and I went on Twitter to
check out if there are any you know
important news in the chess world and I
saw this tweet by Daniel King
he said you play the great game and I
was like who played a great game and
against who did he play it then I saw
this crystal rot room I decided to click
on it so I clicked on a crystal rot room
and I saw that it was in fact a game
against Magnus cross and he was one of
the contenders of the simultaneous
exhibition and then I wrote him a
message via Twitter I asked him did you
indeed play a great game and he said
yeah it was a nice game you know and I
asked him to send me the PGN if if if it
indeed was a nice game and not the not
like the one against the center and
Alexandre Arnold as I so really didn't
enjoy this one but this one was was very
enjoyable so it was played in Hamburg in
Germany here you have the playing hall
there you have twelve chess boards a lot
of room for the audience there were
cameras you know official commentators
Daniel King was one of the official
commentators and you know one of one of
his opponents was a mr. Crist of Rome
he's a 49 year old the journalist he's
been playing chess since he was a
teenager he's working for the manager
magazine as he says it is it's the
biggest business magazine in Germany and
he faces the world chess champion Magnus
calls and so let's see how he did we
have nice to have three cross and of
course has the white pieces as he who
holds a simultaneous exhibition always
has the white pieces we have d5 so
Dority opening is on the board and c4
Carlsen offers the Reta gambit
well you can capture on c4 it doesn't
really gain anything for black white
will simply play III go to pick up this
pawn and you will
I'd be able to defend it or you will run
into a for and face similar problems as
you would for example in Queens gambit
accepted when you're trying to defend
the c4 pawn
so after d5 we have c4 like we've said
and now II six declining the rata gambit
and now comes a b3 cross and transposes
into the English opening we have the AG
encodes the defense on the board Knight
to f6 would have Bishop to b2 and now
comes c5 a very nice move and now III
not allowing black the to push this upon
any further with D with the d4 Bishop to
e7 and now comes the C captures on d5
we have it captures on d5 and now d4 and
with this move costs and places his
pawns on dark squares this light square
bishop can now enter the game and the
one and these two points get exchanged
then his dark square Bishop will also
come alive so a very nice developing
move I will have b6 mr. Christophe also
wants to develop his own light square
bishop Olivia Bishop to b7 and cousin
goes Bishop to b5 this comes with check
so obviously you have to block this
either with Knight 9b d7 or via Bishop
to d7 or you can move the King moving to
King moving the King isn't all that
great of a move so he simply blocks it
with the bishop course and exchanges a
bunch of captures we have a knife
captures also that develops a piece so
very nice for black we have castles
castles and the Knights the c3 calls and
develops upon develops a piece and rook
to c8 black simply keeps developing D
captures on c5 we have knife captures on
c5 you you really want to capture
towards the center but then you're you
left your d5 pawn hanging as the knife
and queen are attacking it so you do
have to capture with the night we have
Knight captures on c5 and now rook to c1
and now Carlsen managed to create an
isolated pawn that black has on d5 it's
a it's a weakness
not immediately but you will have to you
know spend the entire game trying to
defend it as black now has three point
Islands white has two point island so if
you imagine all of the pieces of the
board and the only consider the pawns
and the King's white would have a better
pawn structure and thus the better
endgame so rook to e8 call we have a
nice rook rook development by mr. Kristo
fraud film Queen to e2 cousin also
develops the Queen and prepares to bring
his other look into the game also if
this Knight moves perhaps the Queen can
be used to harass the Queen side Knights
the e6 and at the time he played this
move he said he felt very very good he
felt confident in his position and that
he enjoyed the position very much rook F
2 d1 now I move like Queen to a6 could
be very funny because now you can simply
repeat Knights to c5 and the Queen has
to go back if you capture then you lose
the Queen simply rook to e8 and the
knight is covering b7 and the Queen is
covering b6 so the Queen would be
trapped here so cross and develops the
rook rook F to D 1 and here we have
Bishop to b4 here it's not all that
simple to figure out a plan for black
you might want to go for something like
Queen d7 look c7 and try to get the
other rope to see it perhaps exchange
rooks along the the open C file but
Kristoff said that he didn't feel that
this Bishop to b4 move was that there
was anything wrong with it and in fact
there there isn't there is nothing wrong
with it but it costs and does take
advantage of it by playing Knights to be
5 and now attacking da 7 pawn and now
black has to decide what to do and okay
rook captures don't see one first you
exchange a pair of Brooks Rock captures
on c1 and now a5 an excellent move by
Christoph because if you try something
like a six to protect your pawn with
tempo seemingly attacking the knight
then a knight to a7 would be a bit of a
problem for black as now you're
threatening some ideas with rook to c8
but also opening up a discard attack
from your Queen to the pawn here so not
really something you want to do so
instead of a six a five immediately
now knife to a7 doesn't really make
sense as there is no threat again
the ASX pawn and Bishop to see if I will
simply block off the this file for the
for the rook so after a five we have
Queen to d1 and now comes the Knight to
e4 a very nice idea as black could at
some point capture on f6 and then white
with capture and f6 and black would have
to decide whether he wants to capture
with the Queen and keep his pawn
structure intact or he would but then
lose the d5 pawn or ruin his pawn
structure on the King side and keep
defending the pawn so knife comes to e4
and now comes h3 across and make some
room for his skin you never know what
could happen
Queen to d7 a very nice move comes with
an attack against this Knight and b5 and
also threatening not threatening but
preparing rock to c8 to exchange the
last arrow rooks Knight bTW for by
Carlson and now rock the c8 again an
excellent decision by Christoph as a
capturing the night here would would be
bad for black if you capture them Queen
captures you threaten checkmate here as
the Queen is eyeing the g7 pawn and also
once you stop checkmate perhaps we'd
better to a fate or something then Queen
captures on b6 simply wins upon so after
night B before we have looked the c8
offering a rook trade and now nice to e5
attacking a crystal screen on d7 crystal
plays rook captures on c1 Carlson
recaptures Queen captures on c1 and now
comes Queen to c7 offering a queen trade
and cousin accepts why wouldn't he
Queen captures Knight captures and now
comes Knight d2 c6 attacking the bishop
here and here with Bishop to c3 you
would force a trade of bishops and it
would be very hard to create something
here
for example Bishop captures Knight
captures attacking da to pawn you have
to play a four and now black would still
have this isolated pawn on d5 but with
four Knights and the board it would be a
very happy game so instead after instead
of this Bishop to c3 Christopher goes
and Bishop to c5 and okay also playable
with Knight to d7 by cross and attacking
the bishop once again and here we have
f6
night chapters on c5 Knight chapters on
c5 and now Bush up to a3 a very sneaky
move by Carlson that is that aims at
this Knight captures on a5 move at and
after pawn captures it will leave the c5
Knight undefended but it could have
easily been prevented
for example after this Bishop at X
knight Knight to e4 and now the bishop
on a3 is very awkwardly placed because
if the knight comes to c3 then you will
have no way of defending your a to pawn
as the bishop is blocking it from being
pushed to a4 and the knight cannot
defend it via Knights the before as the
pawn is guarding the be Foursquare so
nine three four a very nice reply to
this special place to remove but here I
will show you this photo just so you
would get a better impression not that
one we already saw that one but this one
here you can see that Christopher was
the last one left playing the
simultaneous exhibition everyone else
finished their games and then everyone
the cameras the lights the audience
everyone was watching his game against
Carlson and Carlson had a he had a chair
brought over so he could sit and play
the game and here he said as a chess
amateur he felt very uncomfortable there
we have Grandmaster Daniel King to the
left also watching the game so a bit
much to take to take for an amateur and
he said that he really I felt nervous
here and that he thought that he would
have to give up at least one of the
pawns here he didn't find this Knight to
e4 idea he thought that he would either
face the bishop captures here and the
knight cappers here or Knight captures
here immediately and then Bishop
captures here so he decided to give up a
point he played King to f7
although we we we mentioned that nice to
e4 keeps the pawn and now comes the
knife captures on a5 you don't want to
recapture and then you get a bunch of
captures and c5 and now you simply have
a bishop against tonight where Coulson
would be up upon not something you want
to not something you want to do so after
Knight chapters on a5 now he plays
Knight to a4 and now Knight to c3 is
still a very nice idea as the a to point
will not be protected but here
son plays Knight to c6 we have Knight to
c3 attacking gay to pawn but now comes
Knights to b4 as there is no more pawn
on a5 to keep the night away from before
now the night is simply protecting the a
to pawn here Carson is up a pawn and
well it's it's a very difficult position
for black not not likely that
Christopher will be able to defend this
so here he said he was already down upon
he didn't feel all that great and still
everyone was watching his game you know
the cameras the the official commentator
and everything and he played the d4 his
idea was upon captors and the Knight to
e2 check
winning back at the pond and then
perhaps continuing from there but the
cousin saw that this doesn't happen he
played a better move that makes this d4
move bad for black he played Bishop to
b2 and now it's a problem now nice to
eat to check doesn't really do anything
King f1 and there's really nothing to do
you have to go back to c3 and you cannot
capture or push d3 because your knight
on c3 would be hanging so here King to
e6 was played King to f1 but by Carlsen
9 3 2 d5 and only now Knight captures on
d5 King captures and now Bishop captures
on d4 here Carlson is up 2 points and
now there's really nothing to do here we
have b5 King to e2 we have f5 now this
is just giving up a pawn but at this
point he already decided to resign so
constant capture than g7 and now being
up three points mr. crystal rot won't
resigned the game and unmoved 36 cousin
won this game but a very nice game and
all up until this moment where King to
f7 was played so like we said instead of
King to f7 simply Knight to e4 a
question in cousins 8 remove bringing
the Knight to c3 and then attacking the
undefended a to pawn here Carson would
have to move the bishop back and then
you can just move the knight back and
cross and we have to figure out another
plan Carson would of course find another
plan and win this game but perhaps he
would have to work harder for his meal
but yeah a very nice game
lasting 27 moves
without being worse against the world
champion an excellent showing by by
Christopher otwal here we also have a
nice photo after all of the games we're
finished Carson handed his playing said
the play Magnus chess to all of the
contenders and here is a nice photo of
Magnus Carlsen and all of the contenders
that were playing this simultaneous
exhibition the fourth annual play live
challenge so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it a much better showing
than that one that we've seen from Trent
Alexander are not so really
congratulations to Christoph on this
excellent game I have no idea how the
other contenders finished you know their
games as I checked the play Magnus
Twitter profile the microscope since the
personal profile and no one said
anything about the result of this
simultaneous exhibition but perhaps I
just missed it somewhere they did
announce that a short video will be
available soon so perhaps they will
announce it there but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it you know
certainly a wonderful experience for mr.
Christopher OTT will surely he enjoyed
it very much
I would like to thank you Yosef Hamada
and the Daniel Garcia for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
and most likely continuing the Bobby
Fischer series and also I would like to
mention that mr. Christopher Rodman
please unleashes under the nickname
master Lee I will put that as well as
some other interesting information in
the description below so feel free to
check it out thank you all and I'll see
you soon